the willingness to start and put in the
10 20 30 hours successful people just do
it and expect to suck at the beginning
and the people who aren't as successful
they they take a decade before they make
the decision to do the first 10 hours
they they just keep going like you just
keep going you make a mistake cool keep
going your podcast sucked keep going you
forgot to press record on an episode
that happened to me keep going like go
go go if we get so caught up about how
we screwed up today or how we screwed up
yesterday that we never make another
thing where the momentum will happen if
you continue to create so self-belief
they just got started and it just kept
going